[Music]
this past weekend the Coachella Music
Festival took place just outside Los
Angeles I think it's bigger and bigger
and bigger
it does this year the festival span two
weekends featured hundreds of music acts
and it was attended by 200,000 people
now the festival ended on Sunday but
apparently someone from our staff is
still there at Coachella his name is
Brandon he works in research and we have
him via satellite let's see if we can
find him here on the satellite there he
is hey can you hear us Brandon it's
Brandon yeah that's that's what I said
yeah no basic Becky's here alright so
okay alright did you see a lot of bands
while you were there
dude it was epic I saw baby juice the
Chipotle Diez chill Cosby genetically
modified orgasm we get it yeah a virgin
Gary jam sandwich rhyme disease Darth
Vader spin Deanna Jones in the temple of
bone yeah yeah we got it that's that's
plenty that's funny oh I love this song
okay
you guys Rock yeah Brandon that's just a
truck backing up okay what what is it
I think that was just jared leto
under your shirt it looks like you're
bleeding what was that Oh chill chill is
just a stab wound I spilled beer on this
guy during sere so he stabbed me
okay so what's with that sort of hair
sticking out I grab CEA's wig and I
shoved it in there to stop the bleed
okay I think we should probably go to
the hospital
Hey I found my girlfriend okay I've been
looking everywhere for you I was so
worried yeah do you have a condom one
wants to know about that
it's
[Applause]
I'm just letting it roll to see how far
the actor will go I don't know okay all
right that's my fault I apologize
we'll take a break when we come to in
dorsal he's doing teeth I've got some
for Celeste come back Kelly Cooper
you